vous êtes heureux et bien en tant
qu'étudiant oui ça marche seulement
sans argent et bien on a les loisirs qui
vous passionnés
des étudiants qui travaillent
parallèlement à leurs études nous
savions tous qu'il en existe
dénicher un petit job pour se constituer
de l'argent de poche ce n'est pas bien
grave et on trouve toujours le temps de
bûcher ses cours dans un bistrot
mais le problème est plus sérieux que ne
le pense ce pour qui des étudiants se
sont des garçons et des filles qui
flânent la longueur de journée sur le
boulevard Saint-Michel en fait 8
étudiants sur dix pratiquent au moins
une fois pendant leurs études un travail
rémunéré c'est un chiffre qui surprend
parce qu'on pense qu'un étudiant devrait
pouvoir consacrer tout son temps à ses
études pourtant le fait est là sur cinq
étudiants qui vont à leur cours 4 ne
font pas que cela 4 gagne de l'argent
ailleurs
et là où la situation s'aggrave c'est
que sur sante étudiants qui travaillent
vint le font par nécessité absolue parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire autrement
s'ils veulent aller jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au diplôme
un organisme privé qui se charge
d'orienter et de préparer les étudiants
à des travaux temporaires ou saisonniers
ils ont lu dans un journal une annonce
qui leur proposait un emploi de
chauffeur de taxi alors il n'hésite même
pas et accepte d'apprendre en quelques
semaines un deuxième métier provisoire
pour pouvoir continuer d'apprendre le
premier celui qu'ils ont choisi ils ne
sont absolument pas qualifiés pour cela
mais ils sont forcés de dire oui
pourquoi parce que le seul travail pour
lequel un étudiant est qualifié c'est la
leçon particulière mais trouver des
leçons à donner cela relève de l'exploit
ou de la chance une offre pour 10
demandes Catherine étudiante en sciences
économiques le c'est bien
c'est pas un
adjectifs
vous avez cherché du travail
pendant les deux premiers mois lorsque
j'ai quitté mes parents j'ai cherché du
travail c'était le grand problème
chercher des leçons au Quartier Latin
c'était impossible à trouver évidemment
parce que tous les étudiants ont cherché
à ce moment-là pourquoi donnez-vous des
leçons particulières
pour gagner de l'argent
je veux gagner de l'argent parce que
pour faire mes études pour vivre pour
cette année est-ce que vous avez
l'impression d'être privilégié de par le
fait que vous pouvez donner des sons
particuliers
certainement parce que j'ai connu ce
petit garçon par des amis alors que j'ai
cherché pendant deux mois dès le son par
différents organismes et qu'il était
impossible d'en trouver sinon des leçons
à
450 francs ou 500 francs c'est à dire
pas des leçons mais des répétitions des
tout petits-enfants pour un étudiant
c'est pas du tout intéressant parce
qu'on perd du temps pour y aller on perd
du temps pour revenir et en trois heures
avoir 500 francs c'est risible vous
savez pour les jeunes il y a deux
problèmes il y a les étudiants qui
travaillent parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'argent et que leurs bourses sont très
nettement insuffisantes
puisado dont les parents peuvent leur
payer des études mais soit pour des
raisons personnelles des histoires de
famille ou des
acompatibilité d'humeur cet objet de
travailler seul catherine est
privilégiée elle a mis deux mois à
trouver cet emploi mais elle est bien
tombée c'est une bonne place elle est
bien payée et ça ne prend pas trop de
temps
autre emploi très recherché c'est la
garde d'enfants le soir pendant que les
parents sortent
Christiane deuxième année de médecine
profite de ses longues soirées
d'attentes pour apprendre l'anatomie
comme ça pas trop de temps perdu
si je restais chez moi je serai quand
même obligé de travailler jusqu'à minuit
à peu près dans mes livres alors et
simplement transport en plus le trajet
mais c'est tout vous assumez combien par
semaine
à peu près 5
ces variables des semaines j'en fais
plus des semaines moins je suppose que
financièrement donc vous en avez besoin
oui plutôt
si je le fais c'est j'en ai besoin pour
pour vivre ce n'est pas pour de l'argent
de poche non
parce que j'ai une bourse mais c'est
comme elle est assez insuffisante pour
vivre j'ai besoin de d'assumer la
différence vos parents vous aident un
peu un petit peu en nature si je peux
dire
mais danse sur le plan la nourriture par
exemple mais j'assume les autres choses
je crois que beaucoup de parents
préfèrent faire garder leurs enfants par
des étudiants en médecine parce que ils
ont ils ressentent une certaine sécurité
ils pensent que s'il arrivait un ennui
elle étudiant en médecine pourrait plus
facilement se débrouiller
éviter le pire c'est tant mieux pour les
étudiants en médecine mais ils ne sont
pas les seules étudiants pour les autres
[Musique]
oui pour les autres pour ceux qui n'ont
pas eu la chance de trouver des leçons
particulières ou qui ne sont pas des
étudiants en médecine pour tout cela que
reste-t-il évidemment beaucoup ne sont
pas concernés par ce problème tous ceux
en particulier dont les parents sont là
pour payer les études et pour lesquelles
manger dans un restaurant ou boire un
verre à une terrasse de café ne
représente pas une dépense insurmontable
ceci répétant le constitue la majorité
des étudiants
mais pour les autres pour ceux qui ont
décidé d'acquérir leur autonomie parce
qu'ils estiment qu'ils n'ont plus à
dépendre de leur famille comme pour ceux
qui ont voulu rentrer à l'université
malgré leur origine modeste il reste le
régime du sandwich avalé debout sur le
trottoir
il reste le hot-dog si on veut se payer
aussi une séance de cinéma
à moins qu'à l'heure du cinéma
[Musique]
on en soit réduit à chercher du travail
aux Halles comme Jean-Philippe étudiant
en sciences politiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous le branche
lui c'est un étudiant en géographie il
est d'une famille pauvre
il a une bourse
depuis combien de temps ça fait 6 mois
c'est depuis le mois de novembre c'est
un travail à plein temps ou un travail
occasionnel un travail tout à fait
occasionnel je travaille une fois par
semaine le mercredi soir
en nocturne de 5 à 10 en réalité ce que
vous êtes sur tous c'est je suis
étudiant en géographie la Faculté des
Lettres à Paris ce travail occasionnel
peut vous effectuez vous le faites par
nécessité ou pour améliorer votre niveau
de vie je le fais pas nécessité
vous avez une bourse oui j'ai une bourse
l'enseignement supérieur mais 2400
francs par an si je divise par 12 ça
fait 20 000 par mois c'est nettement
insuffisant
est-ce que ce travail que vous effectuez
ici vous suffit pour équilibrer votre
budget
en fait oui il me suffit me permet
absolument aucun impair mais il me
suffit
en grosse grande partie grâce au
restaurant universitaire par exemple je
suis obligé de payer ma nourriture tout
seul continuellement en fait vous voyez
ça fait
grosso modo 120 francs par mois
supplémentaire ça porte
l'argent que dont je dispose à 320
francs je peux arriver à joindre les
deux bouts mais vraiment sans plus
étudiant et je vais travailler au moins
cette nuit c'est faisable en ce moment
aussi
ce qu'on m'a dit oui
c'est à dire que
si on a coupé la soudure alors on se
trouve en période de
demi-saison sera difficile ou après vous
veniez le soir vers 10h trouver l'effort
maintenant il paye pas cher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans quelques semaines si tout se passe
bien il sera diplômé de l'École
supérieure des travaux publics en
attendant il travaille dans une
entreprise de transport il conduit des
camions on lui a accordé une bourse elle
est de 270 000 anciens francs par an
vous faites ce travail depuis combien de
temps depuis trois ans
je fais ça tous les jours soit un
travail de chauffeur soit un travail de
bureau cela dépend des exigences de
travail
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je voulais
aujourd'hui
comment vous avez rouler combien de
temps aujourd'hui
c'est beaucoup pour 3h pour 3h non non
c'est normal et le soir vous n'êtes pas
trop fatigué
et le lendemain matin au cours des fois
c'est pénible
quand on a travaillé le soir 4h le soir
et qu'il a fallu encore travailler les
études les cours pendant une heure le
lendemain matin on est croisé
si vous n'aviez pas à faire ce travail
supplémentaire vous pensez que vous
auriez plus de lendemain oui oui
certainement
parce que les coups on me prend mon
travail me prend du temps pendant ce
temps là je peux pas faire de projet or
les travaux publics sont surtout à une
école où on fait pas mal de dessins du
dessin qui prend du temps et le temps je
les trouve pas je le trouve pas là où
normalement un étudiant qui a un
étudiant qui n'a pas besoin de
travailler le trouble parce que en
travaillant 4 heures le soir c'est
quatre heures qui qui partent sur mes
projets et ça ça m'indicap ça c'est net
ça m'indique à midi vous mangez au
restaurant universitaire
universitaire et le soir alors là le
soir je suis embêté parce que
normalement évidemment j'ai droit au
resto à l'université seulement comme je
travaille le soir je suis obligé de
manger au restaurant dans un restaurant
ordinaire privé ce qui me revient à
4 et 500 francs tous les soirs
alors évidemment je bénéficie
pasteur vous arrivez à trouver les
restaurants à 430 oui bien j'en ai un
qui est pas très loin de chez moi là je
commence à connaître la maison alors ces
gens-là sont un peu sympa avec moi
heureusement d'ailleurs et voyez-vous je
mange 400 francs je m'en sors pour 400
francs donc je crois que je suis pas mal
tombé mais heureusement d'ailleurs parce
que 400 francs ça se trouve pas tous les
jours dans votre budget vous arrivez à
consacrer quelque chose à vos loisirs et
bien oui bien sûr mais c'est faible
c'est faible pas beaucoup de cinéma
parce que les cinémas sont très chers
par rapport à un temps un étudiant c'est
très cher et je bénéfice comment théâtre
et bien au théâtre l'année dernière j'ai
eu la chance de qu'un camarade travaille
au TNP le soir bien sûr le soir c'était
dur mais le travail du soir alors
évidemment comme il était employé au TNP
j'avais toutes les premières il me
donnait des billets et j'ai eu toutes
les premières du TNP seulement cette
année ce type là ne travaillait vous a
plu par conséquent de TNP mais coupé
alors j'ai pris un abonnement vous êtes
heureux et bien en tant qu'étudiant oui
ça marche seulement
sans argent et bien on a les loisirs qui
vous passent sous le nez pas mal de
petits loisirs entre autres les vacances
qu'on se trouve bouclés parce que il
faut travailler pendant les vacances
pour repenser à l'année qui suit mettre
un peu d'argent de côté pour les
coupures et sans ça je suis ma petite
vie d'étudiants et péniblement
[Musique]
mais dans quelques mois tout ça sera
terminé
j'ai encore deux mois et demi à faire et
ensuite c'est fini
mais je m'en souviendrai et j'ai pas mal
de caméras qui sont en même temps que
moi j'ai des camarades entre autres qui
travaillent le soir
le soir et au gardien de nuit le truc
ça pas été tellement triomphal cette
recherche de travail
ça dépend des soirs des soirs où ça
marche bien des soirs où on cherche
pendant une heure deux heures trois
heures ça donne rien
ça marche bien comment ça se passe
le soir où ça marche bien c'est au bout
d'une demi-heure une heure on trouve du
travail soit pour toute la soirée puis
ça serait percute maintenant ça marche
bien votre échec à 4h 5h du matin sans
trop de temps mort combien ça rapporte
les bonsoir bonsoir ce rapport
5000 francs 6000 francs 7000 francs
c'est variable ça dépend du travail ça
dépend la fréquence
je suppose que les soirs où il y a rien
du tout on rentre presque aussi fatigué
parce qu'on a cherché
[Musique]
on est fatigué enfin on peut s'arrêter à
deux heures trois heures et puis
abandonner l'employeurs sont gentils
quand ils vous emploient
de problèmes on est étudiant alors ce
qui vous prennent et sont gentil des
fois on se fait rabrouer parce qu'ils ne
prennent pas enfin ça tout ça n'a pas
tellement de contact avec eux vous savez
vous disent prenez la pause sur ce
camion mettez-les là bon c'est fait
c'est fait enfin n'a pas très peu de
contact avec eux pour vous c'est normal
qu'un étudiant soit obligé de chercher
du travail la nuit comme ça
non c'est pas normal enfin
je comprends qu'un étudiant doivent
travailler soit par parce qu'il
personnellement il pense qu'ils doivent
le faire parce que ces situations
sociales lui oblige donc il est pas
normal qu'il est à travailler la nuit
après il va y avoir comme une formule
qui lui permet de travailler pendant la
journée avec une certaine stabilité sans
être obligé de courir les halles la nuit
à la recherche d'un travail très
aléatoire et d'une rentabilité moins
aléatoire ça c'est normal
[Musique]